all right we are now live for the first
AMA session of uh 2023 so New Year
slightly New Look for the thumbnails and
uh we've already got one question here a
very interesting one uh I think that
I've never been asked this question
before
and it's a kind of a cool one when did
you learn how to drive do you have any
advice for first-time drivers so
you know I think a lot of people in
America unless you're living in a really
big city like say New York City or maybe
even Chicago
most Americans learn to drive at one
point or another and you know we even
have like driver's education classes and
uh you know various curricula and
I was kind of an outlier in part because
I was in driver's ed at my local high
school that I wasn't going to but
um I was I was attending it and then I
wound up that summer in juvenile
detention so that was the end of that
and then I I didn't actually get a
driver's license
uh until I was around 20 years old and
I think I I got it because it was kind
of an inconvenience not to have it
um also my mom was getting a new car and
wanted to pass her older car a Pontiac
6000 which was you know kind of a a
beater but for me at that age was a
great car I actually went through quite
a few accidents with it
um and you know came out quite okay so I
was I was like 20 years old and I think
it was the summer and what you have to
do
you know when you're a little bit older
is take a written test and then you do a
driving test you got to fill out some
paperwork and I remember I actually like
lost points on something that I thought
was kind of BS
um on the driving test but you know it
all came out okay and it's kind of funny
that you asked me about that because you
know at the age
that I was at at the time you know 20.
it was like a huge step you know in
driving I think part of what I didn't
like about driving was the fact that you
were responsible for this one ton piece
of metal that could easily go the wrong
way and I thought a lot of my peers were
a little bit too
Cavalier about
um how they how they viewed things but I
I got used to it and then you know I got
to like driving and then I learned how
to drive stick and that was kind of fun
and I drove a dump truck around for a
while I've driven quite a few Vehicles
actually I should I should mention that
when I was in the Army the first thing I
actually learned to drive officially was
a m113 armored personnel carrier
um Vietnam era that we had as as combat
engineers I kind of forgot about that
because I wasn't a driver I I definitely
didn't want to be a driver because it
was like too much extra work and Hassle
and you didn't get it you didn't get
paid anymore for it or have any perks
but I got used to driving and you know I
mean now it's something I just kind of
take for granted you hop in a car and
boom you're off so advice for first time
drivers
um
you know
I would say that it's it's easier to
learn how to drive not right in the
middle of a busy City but sooner or
later you do have to learn how to drive
in cities
and you know a car is a big
responsibility
um
for a lot of people I think it's kind of
a symbol of freedom but it's also you
know there's a lot of work involved in
taking care of a car so that's that's a
very interesting place to get started
with and let's see what else we've got
uh T Douglas has just got here how are
things pretty good you know the semester
is about to begin at Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design I've got two classes
there I'm also doing as I'm going to
make an announcement uh not not today
although you'll hear me say something
about it right now uh but next week
I'm going to be doing a not-for-credit
personal enrichment class on Rene
Descartes meditations and the objections
and replies
and I've got a bunch of other irons in
the fire as well I'm working on a
um book on Epictetus
um
I've got a lot of other things to do
shooting videos podcasts
um I'm doing some local talks here in
the Milwaukee area that I've been
invited to give so there's a lot a lot
of things going on and things are going
pretty good I haven't hit the gym yet
but I'm hoping to get there tomorrow
um
and uh I got a lot of you know cooking
to do and uh my oldest kid will be up
here starting tomorrow again at
University of wisconsin-milwaukee so
we'll get together and that'll be kind
of fun
um actually so I'm going to take Bruce's
thing right here
um because it's relevant to the car
question Bruce says I started driving at
25 years old and taught myself in a
brand new 1977 Chrysler Cordoba that's
you know
That's a classic car now you know so
that's that's kind of cool
um that sounds uh kind of um
kind of fun
um now teaching yourself how to drive
that sounds a little harrowing and I
think Bruce at that time would have
still been in Birmingham so I I can't
imagine in a big city like that driving
around myself I think Bruce perhaps has
more courage that than I do when it
comes to that all right back up to the
other ones Mark is here so happy New
Year hope your festive season was good
here's to another year of great
philosophical discussions it had
anything in particular you're looking
forward to
yeah uh there's a lot of things I'm
looking forward to now looking forward
doesn't mean that they're going to
happen necessarily right
um but yeah there's there's a lot of
stuff that I want to start
doing more writing on
um I've got some
some academic projects that I want to
work on
um some on my own some with with
collaborators and I should mention that
Mark is one of my collaborators as is
um Scott to ruley who some of you have
seen with the the metal shows and then
Harold coveley who just took over
stoicism today stepping into the the
footsteps I won't say boots because I
didn't leave any boots behind but
footsteps I left behind and now he's
he's in charge of that but he and I do a
lot of collaborative work together so
yeah a lot a lot of cool stuff going on
nice to see uh Ken here as well
um happy New Year hope 2023 is a good
year for you I hope it's a great year
for for you as well so all the x is
wishing happy New Year as well Jacob
Murphy have you read any Ian McGill
Crest I've never even heard of Ian
McGill Crest so I haven't I haven't read
them uh David says I was planning to
write a commentary on schopenhauer's
world as will as rep as and
representation any tips on doing a large
writing project what makes you keep
coming back to a commentary so a couple
things there
yeah big big writing projects
um
so there's you know there's like
charting it out and figuring out what
you're going to do aspect to it if you
want to get that published with a
traditional publisher there's also like
Hoops you got to jump through like doing
a book proposal and that can be kind of
a a pain in the butt the first time
around you know as an author you learn a
lot of stuff by making mistakes I would
say
um but I think that a lot of the
planning that you do for something like
that and you know schopenhauer's world
is Will and representation is not a
small book that's that's a big thick
book so a commentary on that would be
quite quite a lot of work
um this is where like you're writing and
research work
kind of comes together with all the rest
of your life right so
this may sound a little
silly but you almost have to pay more
attention to the other things
that you need to focus on in order for
your life to be
not getting in the way of the
intellectual work that you're trying to
do on on schopenhauer for example and
and the other people you know obviously
can't and you know Plato and other
people that he brings up in that
um
so you know like getting regular
exercise making sure that you're taking
care of yourself
um
you know
um
making sure you have what you need in
order to do the work that you want to do
I mean setting yourself up with a good
place to do the reading and work that's
all quite important I would say as far
as my commentary so I did mine is kind
of low-hanging fruit you know I did
those commentary videos on Epictetus
the N Caribbean years ago and then I
remastered them and finished the
remastering I think this summer maybe
this fall and now I'm taking the
um the YouTube transcripts of all of
those videos and going through they're
very raw YouTube gives you basically
just strings of texts that don't have
any punctuation or capitalization
um and sometimes get some of the words
wrong if they're foreign words or if my
accent trips it up and so I'm taking all
of that and editing it and I've released
some of those on medium and I've
released more of those to my patreon
supporters but there's still a lot of
work to be done on that but that's
that's shorter work and then I've got a
former student who is going to do
artwork for it and you know I've got
other people lined up to help me out
with it I'll probably self-publish it
you know through Amazon publishing so
not quite quite the same thing as as
you're looking at doing I think what I'm
doing is a lot easier than writing a
commentary on world is Will and
representation
all right let me take some more
so Leslie says abuse disabled me from
working towards a career marriage and
friendships I sincerely want so I
compromise with a high paying job and
wife despite being gay like Esau losing
his Birthright how can the idea of new
creation and God redeem these
compromises I avoid Temptations but it
seems too late to glorify God by being
Fully Alive well I mean let's take God
out of the picture you know epicurus
says it's never too late to do
philosophy and I think that that's quite
right and by due philosophy doesn't mean
just read books he means like get your
life in order and
um you know attain some some measure of
happiness
um consistently and
it's never too late for for that
although you know there are quite a few
obstacles the older we get the more set
in our ways typically we we are although
sometimes getting older helps you and
you can realize yeah I'm not gonna all
that silly crap over there I don't need
to care what those people think or you
know there's there's uh aspects like
that but um yeah I think there's a lot
of people where it could be abuse it
could be other trauma that people go
through it could be just deprivation it
could be not knowing how things work so
many of us in academics who are
essentially first generation not just
college students but first generation to
go to graduate school
don't don't have a clue how things
actually work in the very rigged game uh
but that doesn't mean that you can't you
know
you know so long as you're still alive
um make some choices for yourself that
would get you some of the things the um
having having a wife who's who's a beard
that's that's kind of tough you know
um but you know
those are things where I mean it's good
to have a high paying job because that
gives you a bit of financial uh security
and uh
you don't have to bust your hump and you
know people come out to spouses all the
time and sometimes the spouses are
really betrayed and ticked off but
sometimes they're they're understanding
so
all right uh Andre is the universe Next
Door by James here worth reading I don't
know I I don't think I've I you know the
the title sounds familiar it might be
something if it's a short story that I
read a long time ago but it does you
know the the author's name doesn't ring
a bell to me so I don't really think I
could say
um
Jordan says I watch a ton of your Hegel
videos I didn't know you were an army
guy when did you get out over three
decades ago you know I was in uh during
the end of the Cold War and when we
started to realize what was called the
peace dividend with the Warsaw Pact
falling apart and they started just you
know
demobilizing people my unit was down to
65 strength by the time that I left
early
um and uh then shortly afterwards you
know totally new Mission uh
Desert Shield started then Desert Storm
but I was out by then so
uh nanessa what is your middle name
Brian I was named after Brian boru uh
the high king of Ireland I think in park
because my mom had so many Irish friends
uh she did the naming of me so Gregory
after Gregory the first or Gregory the
Great you know the the pope who didn't
want to be Pope who uh left some good
writings behind and and did a lot of
important work
Brian and then of course Sadler our fake
family name I say fake because uh you
know I'm I'm adopted to begin with so
I'm not genetically related to the
people who adopted me but my dad was the
first uh in our family to be born as a
Sadler uh because his grandfather
changed it from the Slovenian name
squiffka
um and he did that in part because there
was so much prejudice against Slavic
people especially South Slavs at the
time that that he did that he wanted to
get into business and so he picked the
most English sounding name he could find
so all right uh Sayed says uh would you
recommend any new and interesting
philosophical works or ideas to check
out well so new is relative to all of us
right
um what's kind of cool about philosophy
is you can always find new works without
having to necessarily go and find the
newest thing out there because
philosophy's got such a massive catalog
of works even just in Western philosophy
you know not to to speak of these other
vast philosophical traditions that are
available to us so
um
I mean I don't know what's new to you so
I I don't uh have anything to say about
that
um
I actually I mean a lot of what I'm
doing these days is re-reading
um
I don't know if there are any like works
right now on the horizon for me in
philosophy that are that are new as in
like I haven't read them that I plan to
read but there are quite a few Works in
in other in speculative fiction I mean
there are things like um
you know so
friend and colleague of mine published
this recently and sent me a copy you
know Tim Labon and uh I I haven't read
my way through it yet I've got one entry
in here and so there's a lot of new
stuff like that but it's it's you know
it's about stoicism so that's not
radically new
um so yeah I think I kind of punted that
question there
all right uh
let's see what else we have here a lot
of questions piling up
[Music]
um
emergence as a means of participation
you've mentioned an interest in doing a
retrospective on the value of 20th
century Continental philosophers what
are a couple of the insights you think
are particularly valuable from that
period
yeah I mean I don't know that I just
thought of doing 20th century I mean
there's 19th century thinkers as well
and
I mean I've actually thought about doing
a a short book
um sort of a critical
evaluation of Hegel like what Hegel got
right because there's an awful lot that
Hegel got wrong what what can we draw
from uh his his ideas and I think you
know the notion of recognition is
absolutely Central for that but if we're
if we're thinking about 20th century
thinkers
um
you know so like darita for example
there's an awful lot of silly
joking around and
showing off and stuff like that and some
things that I think are just wrong in in
Dairy does work but you know this notion
uh rightly interpreted of there's
nothing outside of the text there you
know or text there isn't an outside of
textuality I think that's actually quite
correct doesn't mean that everything's a
text but it means that you can't ever
get completely away from it
um or you know Gilda loses discussions
of the function of Law and some of his
later works you know like in katika
Clinique
um I think that's
that's a good set of realizations
um you know Heidegger obviously has a
lot of cool things to contribute as do
um Gabriel Marcel and uh
uh Jean-Paul sarte and Camus and all
these these people that we typically
talk about as existentialists
um you know I like Harbor Moss's
discourse ethics
and the the idea that we should try to
work out consensus on important matters
together you know so those are those are
some interesting
points you could say and we'll see how
how much progress I ever make on this
other bicameral monk oh here's an easy
one for me to answer what is your
favorite Dostoevsky book uh the one
that's translated the title either as
the demons or the possessed that's
that's my favorite
um a lot of people want to Wade their
way through Brothers karamazov as if
like that's the big achievement
I actually found large parts of Brothers
karamazov
kind of I won't say boring but
you know
making me say why the hell am I reading
this when I could be reading something
else
um
you know the the uh the idiot it's been
a long time since I read it but I kind
of felt like I never got the point of it
crime and punishment is okay you know
um obviously
um
uh
the under you know Notes From The
Underground is is great but the demons
just has
for me it's like the best developed uh
Dostoevsky novel so that's the one I
prefer
um
sand says I started working through
lacan seminars
and I often struggle to fully comprehend
what he's trying to say
do you have any tips for tackling as
Corpus fruitfully
yeah I mean
I would say
you're probably not going to understand
necessarily everything that he's saying
unless you're putting an awful lot of
time
into it and I you know I I Lacon is one
of those people where
so there's two things to say one is that
he he's unnecessarily like Dairy da he's
unnecessarily
um complex and precious in the way that
he writes and that's you know sort of
like
um
past the World War II
French prose in philosophy there's an
awful lot of cleverness there that
doesn't need to be there
um that I think people eventually you
know like 100 years 200 years from now
there'll be some people who like that
and a lot of people be like you just
gotta like get through that that stuff
the other thing is um I mean sometimes
Lacon is just kind of experimenting and
you know he'll go down a blind alley
and you know like everybody else he
hasn't read everybody he's got opinions
on all sorts of things he can be wrong
about stuff so you know I would say if
you feel like you can at least tell
yourself I think here's what's going on
you're probably doing okay with him I
don't have any like great tips for for
reading his uh his stuff
um
I mean you could say this
that
lacan is not just farting around for the
sake of farting around
he actually sooner or later has to like
make people's lives somewhat better not
cure them but you know at least improve
their their lives and give them a bit
more autonomy and in deciding what
they're going to do and you know insight
and stuff like that so
all right
um Arcturus I've heard you refer to a
category of French reflexive philosophy
but couldn't find anything when looking
it up so would you please refer to the
main figures in this movement well I
mean it's not hard to find so I'm not
sure where you are looking it up but
it's not a category it's just sort of a
designation
um and I I think you should be able to
find stuff online about it pretty easily
Marie's Blondell is uh uh you know a
reflexive philosopher I think you could
say that Gabrielle Marcell is as well
um
Jacques palier
um is is a good example
um and it's you know it's it's a
um it's not a movement per se where
there was like a Manifesto or anything
it's just kind of a way of doing
philosophy where you're paying attention
to how the mind is indeed reflexive and
not just the intellect but the will and
things like that so
um but I think if you type in you know
in quotes reflexive philosophy French I
would bet you there's going to be some
stuff that would come up on Google
lickety-split as a matter of fact let's
uh make an experiment
um
perplexive
philosophy let's just see what comes up
with reflex well first thing that comes
up Paul rakur right and so the Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy his early
academic training was in the tradition
of reflexive philosophy right so it's
not like you
um
if you if you search you're not going to
find stuff coming up right away so all
right
um
Alexander do you have an opinion on
philosophers like Nick Bostrom and
William mcaskill or effective altruism
long-termism generally I haven't read
Bostrom or mccaskill effective altruism
I mean the person that I you know most
familiar with is singer right who and an
effective altruism and
utilitarianism have a lot of overlap
they're not exactly the same but
um close enough I think in in many
respects
um
I mean I think that there's there's a
lot of good points to it I I think that
you know with utilitarianism there's a
lot of good points to it I don't buy
into it as an overall
um guiding Philosophy for everything the
way some people do
um but then again I'm not a movement
Joiner you know I think a lot of people
need to have something that they feel is
like grounding everything for them
um
interestingly we're discussing effective
altruism in connection with
utilitarianism in My Philosophy
mindfulness and life class at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design This uh
semester which I need to get my my uh
button gear because I haven't opened the
class yet for my my students
all right uh Patrick I've heard you
mentioned once that you're a Catholic
what do you think is the best reason to
believe in the Christian God I grew up
Catholic but I have become more agnostic
over time I don't think there's a best
reason I think that um I kind of agree
with William James when it comes to this
sort of stuff and you know also Pascal
and Maurice Blondell and people like
that
um there is an a best reason there's a
whole bunch of different things that we
can decide whether they count as reasons
for us and sometimes we are in a
situation where we are unable to see
these things as good reasons and that
could be a failure on our part or on you
know culture that we've absorbed or
stuff like that but typically when
people people aren't aren't you know
converted or or reinforced in their
faith by traditional apologetics I'm
always very suspicious of people who are
big on apologetics because I tend to
think that there's an awful lot of
emotional stuff going on under the
surface that is unacknowledged there and
same thing by the way for apologetics uh
for for atheism there's an awful lot of
atheists whose position is essentially
just you know emotionally driven too
um so I you know I tend to think that
you want to know about a religion well
you study its key texts and then you see
what it's great thinkers have had to
contribute you see how people live that
way and what it contributes to their
life and you kind of experiment with it
you know so if you're Catholic maybe you
say the Liturgy of the Hours and you see
whether that has any interesting effects
on you or you take anselms proslogian
and use it the way it was originally
intended to not as a philosophy of
religion you know argument in week four
of the class but rather as a a
meditation or something like that so
all right
um
getting asked about a lot of people I
don't know uh Francesca Francesco says
have you ever heard of the philosopher
from Southern Italy called Pasquale
galupi
no I have never heard of him uh but that
I mean that doesn't mean anything about
the quality of people there's probably
you know tens of thousands of
philosophers I've never heard of
says I wanted to ask you a very general
question how do you find yourself
interested in a certain philosophy like
what motivates you one day to go read
Hegel or epicurus well nothing motivates
me one day to go go read them I it's
usually that like something led to
something else led to something else
um and I I'm actually you know I'm not a
good person to ask about that because
I've been reading and studying
philosophy now for over three decades so
I'm I'm probably closer to the end of my
studies because you know
I could die before I reach 82 than I am
to the the start of it
um and a lot of a lot of philosophers
you know I encountered at one point and
I was like oh maybe I should go back and
check that stuff out you know or it's
somebody references them and I'm like ah
you know maybe there's something more
there I should go read you know so
all right uh
uh T Douglas says I'm a high school
senior in Canada idea been floating
around with my friends is starting a
philosophical Journal got any advice
yeah don't make it a printer and I'll
make it online uh because
printing you know costs money right and
there's all sorts of things involved
with it I I actually started a journal
at one point in time and it was a
complete flop
um that was
well over 20 years ago
um
it's an awful lot of work to keep a
journal going well
you know a lot of people will say
they're going to do something and then
they they don't do it I'll write a book
review for you you know and then they
they take the book and they don't write
it you gotta you know
it's a lot of hassles
um
and you know the other bit of advice
that I would give you
would be maybe get yourself involved
with some other journals maybe you've
already done this but you know get
yourself on you know uh the editorial
board or be a reviewer or something like
that for journals and um
you know then you get to see some of how
the the proverbial sausage is made and
that will help you when you decide to
start your own journal later on down the
line you know
um
so Cola asks have you seen any
thought-provoking films recently
I don't think I've watched a full-length
movie
for quite a while
um
my viewing
is mainly
watching shows with my wife or watching
uh shows on my own which is typically as
I'm going to sleep you know so like I've
been re-watching Red Dwarf uh which is
you know good fun sci-fi uh definitely
not hard sci-fi but a you know funny uh
character oriented Sci-Fi show from uh
Britain from the 1980s maybe going into
the 90s
um
yeah so I haven't watched any any movies
lately so I don't have any any material
there to to recommend
um
Alexander says do you think it's useful
to group philosophers like Aleister
McIntyre Charles Taylor and Michael
sandel together under the communitarian
label
I mean I've never found it useful myself
because
you know when I look at and I'm familiar
with all three of them much more with
McIntyre's work than Taylor's or or
sandal but they were all like big names
back in the 90s when I was coming up in
in grad school
um I've never really enjoyed reading
Charles Taylor and so that's kind of an
impediment whereas I do enjoy reading
sandal and McIntyre
um
and I find some of Taylor's assertions
like you know interiority begins with
Augustine I what that's crazy nonsense
that you know shows that a lack of
Engagement with sufficient uh
pre-christian and uh uh you know early
Christian philosophy
um
I mean I think when it comes to these
labels you got to ask well what work is
the label doing are you using the label
so that you can identify certain traits
that you think these philosophers have
in common or so you can predict what
they're going to say next without
actually having to read what they say on
particular things I mean there's a lot
of places where
um sandal and McIntyre and Taylor are
not going to be on the same page
um
so
you know I I don't know how helpful it
is and communitarian
there's not a lot of like real
substantive discussion of that
these days in political philosophy as
far as I could tell yeah maybe I'm
misinformed but yeah
all right
um
let's see here
June says new to your AMA wanted to ask
M.A philosopher M Phil for legal
scholarship and energy Justice I don't
have a clue I mean
um that would be something that you'd
want to ask people who work in those
fields you know
um and when it comes to like thinking
about programs you got to look at each
individual program as its own separate
animal it's not as if there's like a
standard uh M.A in philosophy right it's
going to vary from school to school to
school
um Jordan you've alluded to the
difficulties of being a first generation
academic how do you deal with going from
the military to Academia was it a rough
transition or were you into philosophy
during your time in
I mean none of those really apply
um
I mean I didn't go straight from the
military into Academia what I did was I
got out uh in March of 1990 and I moved
you know I moved back in with my mom in
Waukesha
and I did what I did before which is uh
work in in restaurants I walked I
literally just walked down Highway 18
and uh put in job applications at the
places that were within walking distance
nearby except for Ponderosa where I had
already worked and knew I didn't want to
go back to and Shakey's Pizza I've done
a video about Shakey's Pizza but way
Shaky's Pizza got back to me and they're
like hey you want to come in and do prep
and you know and then I bartended there
for a while and you know I cooked and
dishwashed and did all the actually went
on deliveries as well and after a while
I was like man this sucks you know maybe
I should go to college
um but I had no intention of going into
Academia going to college and going into
Academia two totally different things
right
um the one going to college is a is one
of the many prerequisites for the other
but I had no idea that I was going to go
to grad school or anything like that and
you know I knew I knew a little bit of
philosophy I've man I've talked about
this at other places
I had some philosophy stuff in in high
school my actual philosophy class sucked
the the class that I learned real
philosophy in was was a sacraments class
where the teacher who's a substitute
just happened to teach about Plato and
Aristotle and Augustine and you know
stuff like that
and then you know I probably read a book
about philosophy that I bought at the PX
while I was in the Army but I wasn't
like studying it so you know I got to
college and uh fall of 1990 and
um things just kind of fell into place
you know I had high test scores so they
gave me some financial aid and they put
me in the French house because they knew
that I was from a francophone family and
they they were trying out this new
experimental thing and
um then you know I took some philosophy
classes and also math classes and
had majors in both of those but I was
doing a lot of stuff with art you know I
worked for the art Department as a
carpenter and docent and model and I was
playing my bass you know and doing music
stuff and a lot of partying so it's not
like at that time I was like yes I'm
going to be a professor I mean I never
intended to go to college in the first
place
and then when I did I didn't go to the
you know the right place uh or or study
things in the right way I just kind of
studied whatever the hell I wanted to
and my professors in philosophy kind of
sucked you know and then I got done
there and I uh came down here to
Milwaukee and lived here for a year uh
just working as a third shift security
guard and you know I'd read some
philosophical literature uh like I
worked my way through being in
nothingness again in a in a serious way
and studied languages and then you know
at the end of that went off to uh Quebec
and to Europe for like a summer and then
went right into grad school at Southern
Illinois Carbondale which again if if
I'd known anything about how the game
works in philosophy I would have
probably gone to some of the other
schools that accepted me and applied to
different schools but yeah you just
don't know right so the military thing
had nothing to do with that
um other than you know like
there's some things that you never
really lose like walking at 120 steps
per minute you know like marching or
um
a certain predilection for cleanliness
you know so yeah so it wasn't I mean
actually being in the military
[Music]
probably made it easier for me to be
able to indulge myself and yet have the
discipline to keep myself on track in in
school you know
um
but yeah that's that's probably all I
have to say about that
um
all right uh Elijah says I am
considering a career in law
any advice on how to decide whether to
pursue a career in law I also have the
opportunity to attend medical school and
need to decide between the two
um you know there's a couple things you
could do you could look at I mean first
off you should be talking with doctors
and lawyers about the kind of work that
they're doing
uh and what they think sucks about it
and what the prospects are for their
jobs going forward you know
um that'd be much more helpful than
talking to a philosopher and
um you know you want to try to look at
whatever information you can find about
what the likelihood of making a decent
living and having a good you know
lifestyle that you want to have
um 10 20 30 years down the line in these
fields I mean there's there's areas
where AI is is projected to make some
pretty serious inroads into how things
are done in law and medicine so you want
to be attentive to those sort of things
and you know look at the
um
look at the rigors that are required for
the years that you're in I'm in law
school
basically you got three years study for
the bar past the bar right and then you
got to work for people right so I
there's something kind of like a
residency but you know they're not going
to make it partner right away right
medical school you know you've got
pre-med and then you go to med school
and then you're a doctor but you have to
be a resident and being a resident sucks
right and then uh you get out and you
get to do it whatever it is that you're
gonna do so those I think those are all
things that you would want to
take into consideration
in making that decision
um Zeno says what do you think of zero
books publication
um the dust of this planet Eugene
Thacker is one of them
you know
I haven't paid that close attention of
what's been happening at zero books I
know there was a lot of like
um
having to do a thug Lane a while back
like some controversy but I didn't
really pay close attention to it I I
admittedly don't read zero books much
um
I mean I I can't say that I've read any
of their books I've paged through a few
um
but you know I'm not I'm not really
connected with them
um so I don't really have much to say
about them
uh Damon Forbes anything on Charles
Bukowski and existentialism seems to me
is the American Dostoevsky I'm not
impressed with Bukowski
and maybe you know maybe I need to give
him a reread
um he always struck me as being sort of
like a knockoff Norman mailer
um just a little bit more tawdry and you
know the other thing that kind of turned
me off is like every dirt bag who had
literary pretensions back in the 90s was
a Bukowski fan sort of like how you know
you get like the David Foster Wallace
you know uh fan club every once in a
while coming up as well and I'm not I'm
not really into that kind of stuff you
know I mean
Bukowski
um
he lived a certain kind of Lifestyle
which I guess you could say intersected
with the lifestyle I lived at certain
points
um although it didn't it wasn't
identical with it and um
I I always just found him kind of
you know
tendentious
um so I don't really have a lot of of
good to say about him quite frankly
um
there's a question here could you please
share your opinion of Hayden White's
philosophy of History I don't have an
opinion on Hayden White's philosophy of
History I'm getting asked about a lot of
people who I don't really read uh
Alexander who in your opinion are the
most overrated
philosophers oh that's a tough one I
mean
you know
this is going to seem really a weird one
uh Ein Rand
right because the people who are really
into Iran think that like she is the
best thing since sliced bread and she is
a philosopher you know academics oh
she's not a philosopher they're they're
actually being elitist and full of crap
um but she's like a third-rate
philosopher who is really awful when it
comes to interpretations of the people
she likes and dislikes you know like you
you can't go to Rand for any genuine
interpretation of Kant or Plato or
Nietzsche and he also can't go to
conference or for any interpretation of
Aristotle because even even though she
loves him she loves
somebody who's not really Aristotle
which by the way she has in common with
many Thomas as well who are you know
kind of piss-poor readers of of
Aristotle and sometimes even of Thomas
Aquinas
um
so you know the the popularity that she
has the general popularity over here
um makes her kind of uh overrated but
not for not for a lot of the people in
the academy
in the Academy I mean yeah who who
should we think of
foreign
that's a good question
because there aren't that many
philosophers who are actually held in
really high esteem
there's a lot of pseudo philosophers
right there's like the whole tier of
gurus people that are part of the
popular culture and they're kind of
occupying the space that good
philosophers should occupy like Jordan
Peterson or Sam Harris or
um Jonathan height or all these public
intellectuals whose whose work is you
know often you read it you're like this
is kind of sloppy crap you know
um
but that's sort of shooting fish in a
barrel actual philosophers who are
overrated
that's a good question
um
I mean I think it depends on where you
are
because you can go to a you know you can
go into a discourse where people are
like you know you've got to read this
person or else you're not really in
touch with philosophy and and anytime
somebody says something like that you
can be like
yeah I think we were doing philosophy
before they came on the scene and we'll
probably still be doing it even if we
haven't read them
um so you know in certain areas like the
latest analytic darling or Continental
darling or pick whatever else you want
would would kind of fit in with that
um but I think you'd have to like it
would have to be according to like what
place
people are looking at
um I you know I did this thing about
text with auras uh quick takes and all
of them except for Nick land of course
who I I don't think particularly highly
of
um but I also don't think is is you know
the stuff in Fang Newman I don't think
is crap
um I think some of his later stuff is
pretty pretty crappy
um you know all the other people like
you know Benedict Spinoza or you know
Dairy die or people like that they're
they're they're good philosophers
um they're not overrated but there's a
lot of people out there talking about
them without having spent much time with
the tax who like talk them up to the
skies and so they could be over
overrated in that sense right
all right Gilgamesh says I've got some
confidence and anxiety issues when I
socialize I'm very self-conscious do you
know any thinkers who've had the same
issues or at least wrote about
confidence
uh yeah there's lots of thinkers who've
written about confidence and many people
have had those sorts of
um
affects and and worries including myself
you know
um when I was younger
I had this thing where I felt like I was
always being watched
you know and so I need to like make sure
that my behavior was the right sort and
all that and it was so liberating to
realize that most people don't pay
attention to most of what's going on
around them most of the time
um
and there's lots of different you know
causes and and modalities of anxiety
that can arise I mean the stoics are are
particularly good for that I mean
Epictetus actually has all sorts of
discussions about fears and anxiety and
what it is that we're actually worried
about thinking these things through and
how to have confidence what to be
confident about
um you know a lot of this winds up being
a matter of um
changing your mindset through
experimentation and practice and you
know like reminding yourself of of
things over and over again it might be
helpful to like do this with other
people like a therapist or a coach or
support group or
um friends who who are interested in
that sort of thing as well
all right uh Dr G boss I've been
thinking about deception from a
philosophical point of view would like
to know if there's any text on this lots
of texts yeah I mean Augustine comes to
mind he's actually got two different
treatises online you know you know as a
matter of fact you could go to
um Sizzle a box famous book lying and
you know look at the bibliography that
she has in the back of it and take off
from there there's there's lots and lots
and lots of references to deception and
lying there's I mean think about Plato's
allegory of the cave right so there's
probably too many to uh to count up and
you know you could distinguish between
modalities like deceiving but not lying
lying
um you know creating situations of
deception being deceived oneself but
there yeah there's I mean it's been uh
heraclitus talks about it right the
majority authority of human beings don't
know what the hell they're doing they're
all mixed up about stuff right
right uh so AOC time okay here we go
hope you're having a wonderful new year
in your personal experience what is
something that all outstanding student
papers have assuming there is such a
thing I I don't think there is such a
thing I mean other than being excellent
right which doesn't doesn't help us out
at all you know that's uh if we want to
figure it out I mean
that's that's a that's an interesting
question because
[Music]
um
excellent student papers
are often excellent for different
reasons right
and I mean we could say some generic
things like well they exceed
expectations
um they're better than the usual paper
but that's that's all kind of relative
isn't it to the expectations or how
everybody else is doing
um I mean what I really like to see is
serious engagement with whatever it is
that we're we're studying and the
student having done work on their own
and I also like and this this is not
Universal right but I like to see a
student looking at the same thing from
multiple points of view and figuring out
why one point of view is better than the
others at least at that point in time
for for them right so
all right uh maximum what do you think
is the best Hagel book to get started
with Hegel
um well it's going to be a book by Hague
oh not a book on Hagel because I think
you should you should actually make a
stab at uh primary text I I recommend
not starting with the phenomenology uh
my consistent recommendation
is that uh you start with the lot the
lectures on the philosophy of history or
the lectures on the history of
philosophy because they're easier
um a bit more you know naming names
telling you who the hell he's talking
about whereas the phenomenology
um and you can also say this about the
logic and even philosophy of right uh
which are like the Masterworks you know
there's not a lot of you have to do a
lot of like figure out who the hell is
he talking about here right
um but those those lectures are easier
to make your way into
um I mean some people like to start
people off with reason and history which
is not bad I guess that that's not a
terrible way to go
but yeah that's that's maybe the way to
to do things
um
here's another one from I I can't read
Cyrillic stuff so I'm I'm not going to
try to pronounce this
could you give any recommendations on
the post-docs for philosophy political
theory in the U.S and Canada I'm
finishing my PhD in September so I'm
trying to get information on that matter
I cannot give you any information on
that matter because it's not something
that I do any work on
um I can say this that you know just
like every department is its own animal
every postdoc is its own animal and you
wanna you know you wanna go to people
that are closer to that particular thing
that you're applying for
um so
all right
um somebody's got what I think is Arabic
here how to remember what you've read
I don't know uh different people use
different things I don't really rely on
monomic devices I've been fortunate in
that I was blessed with a pretty decent
memory and I connect things up together
but you know sometimes I forget things
as well I don't worry too much about it
um at this point in my career
um but I can tell you like when I was
learning languages lots and lots and
lots of drills you know actually using
what it is that you're you're working
with
um when I was memorizing things for the
uh
uh tests that I had to take at the
Masters and PhD level going over the
material over and over again and making
notes and diagrams for myself that I
found helpful were what I did but other
people did other things you know
all right uh TL stock says I appreciate
your work I was first introduced to
existentialism via Walker Percy and
haven't looked back since
uh oh well okay yeah that's I mean
I guess he's considered an American
existentialist so yeah
um
Francesco says for you as Jorge Louis
Borges closer to speculative fiction
than he is to magical realism so that's
a category mistake magical realism is a
kind of speculative fiction
there's all different kinds of
speculative fiction think of speculative
fiction as being like the super category
the super genre that has a whole bunch
of different genres underneath it which
include magical realism and include
fantasy science fiction horror weird
superhero alternate history
utopian dystopian all of those are
speculative fiction so that means that
speculative fiction as a category is not
super helpful right
um Borges is very very philosophically
oriented when you you know look at his
stuff
um I mean there are some stories where
there's not any explicit reference to
philosophy as such but there are quite a
few where there there is so
um
you could you could say either of those
fit in there and you ask about Alejo
Carpentier I have no idea who that is
Macedonia Fernandez macedoni Fernandez
never wrote anything apparently so
um all we know is like what people have
said about him and Salman Rushdie I
don't know about Rushdie because I don't
read him so I don't read a lot of uh
20th century 21st century modernist
stuff
you know
um I'm not I'm not well read in in those
sorts of things in part because uh you
know you got 24 hours a day how much are
you going to spend on these big names
you know as opposed to other stuff
uh Anthony Loreno thoughts on Jonathan
Hyde I don't take him very seriously he
likes get dichotomies that in my view
are kind of sloppy and don't hold up and
I I you know I think he kind of brings
discredit on his uh profession
um in some of the stuff that he that he
says
um
Lord Roku how familiar are you with
Theology and current Academia what's
your take on it
theology like philosophy is an
incredibly vast Spectrum so there is no
such thing as Theology and current
Academia there's all sorts of
theological approaches and traditions
and schools and questions and stuff like
that nobody
nobody out there is uh conversant with
all of it it's just impossible just like
it would be impossible to do for
philosophy so I don't really have a take
on theology in current Academia because
I mean it's sort of like trying to say
something about
um you know an island chain and the
tendency is to focus in on one or two
islands rather than on the other 200 or
so that are that are out there
uh stoic shraven have you read ancient
Hindu philosophy yeah I mean I've even
taught classes on non-western philosophy
and religion but I'm not an expert on it
and I don't read Sanskrit
um so you know I I generally leave the
doing videos and stuff like that about
that to people who actually can do that
same thing with ancient Chinese
philosophy right I don't I don't read uh
more than a few characters in in
Mandarin well in Chinese the the dialect
that I can
speak a little bit of his Mandarin and
that's you know the Contemporary stuff
not classical Chinese so I I leave that
to the other people who are better
experts on that
uh Max says would like to thank you for
the Anselm concept vids going through
the monologian and finding his approach
and ideas and how God works that's a
good way to put it how God works uh and
at least what we can figure out about
how God works fascinating yeah that's uh
that's uh pretty good
um Anselm is a unusual thinker you know
um there's gonna be a podcast episode
because I did an interview recently
the hell's I can't remember the name of
the podcast it's it's an Irish guy who
was interviewing me that'll be coming
out recently
it'll be coming out soon uh about Anselm
and his approach and and we talk about
the prosologian and monologian
um we don't get into the other works
uh Pat what's your favorite period of
Western Art I mean I don't know that I
have one
um I think if you were to ask me back
when I was like a college student I
would have said like the Impressionists
but
I don't I don't know that I actually
have
favorites these days
when it comes to that sort of thing I
mean I love going to
museums and I also love working in a
place like Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design where you know every floor is
filled with a student and sometimes
faculty art and an alumni art and then
you know the basement uh has two
galleries that there's exhibitions in
all the time as well we're really quite
fortunate living where we do here in
Milwaukee we've also got the saint
Kate's Art Hotel we've got this amazing
art museum just
a mile and a half down the road from
from us so
I don't really have favorites like that
um
communizer Hagel once said you're either
a spinozist or not a philosopher at all
what are some ways Spinoza influence
hegel's thought
I would say not for the best
um
and you know people love slogans and
stuff like that but a lot of that stuff
is kind of silly and this is this is in
the category of the silly
um I a lot of those German idealists
were attracted to Spinoza's pantheism
and
um
you could you could call it a rejection
but let's call it a reinterpretation of
teleology
but if you look at what hagel's doing
and then you map it on to Spinoza
Spinoza looks pretty poor in comparison
even as wrong as Hagel is on a lot of
things like you know the nature of
history and its end he at least has
stuff about history and Spinosa doesn't
I mean Spinoza kind of does in
the um the tractatus theological
politicus but not not in the ethics
right
[Music]
um
so I mean I don't take those sorts of
quips very seriously uh they're
certainly not something I would use to
orient my thought
Yannick says after studying Plato's
works by myself I'm unsure about how to
move on
which philosopher would you recommend is
the second step on my self-study journey
well I mean you can pick whoever you
want you could if you like the character
of Socrates why not read some xenophon
another
student of Socrates won't take you as
long to read as Plato because we don't
have as much by identified and you could
maybe skip some of the stuff that
doesn't have to do with Socrates like
the uh the anabasas you know the March
up or the education of Cyrus or you
could read that stuff or you could read
Aristotle I mean that's kind of a
natural way to go
or you could look at um you know the
things that we have of these minor
Socratic schools like the Syrian ax that
won't take you long or the cynics
um
you know there's all sorts of ways you
could go you could also like jump way
ahead and read uh middle plateness like
Plutarch and you know
um elkinus
uh or read later platonists
it's all it's it's up to you there's
there's nobody who's you know behind you
who's gonna
wrap your hand if you if you read the
wrong person next you know
so all right
um
Patrick could you recommend three books
to start with to better understand
Christian thought
um yeah I mean
if if you want to
um
understand where stuff is coming from
obviously you have to read the gospels
right because these are where we're
getting the story of this Jesus guy from
in really important determinative ways
um
and you know it all depends on what
you're looking for I mean do you want to
like try to read some of the greatest
ideas by the greatest thinkers do you
want to read contemporary stuff do you
want to uh read the earliest uh
Christian philosophers I mean Justin
Martyr would be somebody or lachtancius
would be somebody that you'd want to
read then
um there's all different sort of options
and and I'll tell you this this might be
an interesting answer to your to your
question
so Paul Griffiths great Augustine
scholar guy who was a Buddhist for a
long time
um from England studied here in
Wisconsin at UW Wisconsin uh Madison uh
bumped all around uh I think his last
teaching appointment was at dude but I
think he's Emeritus from there now
um at the University of Illinois at
Chicago
back in the days when he and I used to
correspond
um he taught a class and it was called
like introduction to Catholicism right
and the three books that he used for
that were Augustine's confessions
portions of of uh Thomas aquinasama
theologia
and Pascal's passes
kind of an interesting approach isn't it
you know I mean I'm not sure that I
would necessarily have picked those
three myself but they're certainly up
there you know so you know I think
that's that's quite good
all right
um
emergence as a means of participation
any recommendations for additions of
Gabriel Marcel's Works in English
yeah whatever you can get I mean I don't
know that there's like multiple
translations you just Google Gabriel
Marcel and go to Amazon and you'll see a
ton of his books come up like you know
for example the homo Viator right so the
translation of this
translated by Emma Crawford and Paul
Seton it's probably the only translation
out there I don't think you need to
worry about additions just get your
hands on some and you don't necessarily
even need to buy them you could probably
find them at your local library at least
some of them so
all right Nick alonto I'm wondering if
you're going to make videos about
analytic philosophy I've already made
lots of videos about analytic philosophy
I mean if you know what analytic
philosophy is and who are the people
involved in the movement are all you got
to do is look at the numerous core
concept videos that I've done on uh
analytic thinkers and question answered
right
uh communizer have you read any Carl
Schmidt I remember in one of your four
book book four book tour videos you have
some of Anga men's works yeah I mean I I
I think everybody
back in the day read some Carl Schmidt
and he's okay but he's not you know
awesome and again Ben is you know okay
but not like awesome so sure
um
um all right let's see what else we have
here Joseph says how can we connect the
dots between ancient philosophical
tradition versus modern do they
complement or are they opposed so you're
not going to like what I have to say
which is that there's no such thing as
ancient philosophical tradition or
modern philosophical tradition they are
both plural and the way you connect the
dots is by actually reading the
philosophers and seeing who the hell
they talk about I mean this is pretty
straightforward uh you read Descartes
and you can be pretty clear that he's
taking some stuff from the stoics who
are quite popular at the time that he's
writing right or you read David Hume and
you see the many references that he
makes to ancient thinkers
he's even got essays the platonist the
Epicurean the stoic the skeptic so that
I mean that kind of tells you about
these not tradition but traditions of
um
ancient philosophy right which we're
being talked about in the modern period
so you want to avoid schematic
treatments of things right so wherever
you got the idea that there's an ancient
philosophical tradition singular whoever
told you that get rid of them because
they're full of crap you know
um spend instead spend your time
actually reading ancient philosophy uh
in multiple traditions and you'll get a
really good sense of what's going on
um
yeah it says how would you define who is
a philosopher versus a rhetorician pop
philosopher I don't Define so that's
kind of a non-starter there where do
borderline examples like uh jbp kamu
Louis Dante Hawking Etc Paul kamu is a
philosopher kamu is not a pop
philosopher he's not a rhetorician Camus
is a hardcore philosopher read the rebel
and and you'll see that you know
um
jbp
is that Peterson's middle name
Peterson's not not a philosopher he's a
psychologist and kind of a you know kind
of a bullshitter uh Lewis you probably
mean C.S Lewis not David Lewis right
because I was kind of thinking about
that David Lewis
you know the possible worlds guy really
set the agenda for a lot of analytic
Philosophy for about two decades uh
giving giving some important vocabulary
C.S Lewis
um not just a rhetorician you know he's
he's definitely within the scope of
philosophy Hawking Hawking is kind of a
weird guy because I don't think he's
actually studied enough philosophy to
opine about philosophy
um but I don't worry about defining this
I don't worry about Drawing the Line
what I worry about is reading enough
good stuff so that you can like sort of
like listening to enough good music
where you could be like that stuff over
there is not very good right
uh metaphysics how can studying logic
and philosophy benefit us I mean those
are two different topics right so
studying logic just like studying
mathematics helps to you know build
certain habits of mind but it's not
always directly applicable to life and
there's kind of a mistaken uh attitude
that people have like oh I can put
everything into syllogisms you know
um studying philosophy much broader
topic I mean a lot of philosophy is
practical philosophy so it you know how
can studying uh stoicism or epicureanism
or other philosophies of Life help you
by helping you figure out how to run
your life
I mean that's that's pretty
straightforward so
yeah
um
Jordan says do you have an opinion on
the uh dlfs stick Logics where
contradictions can be true do you think
those sort of systems can be truth
tracking they feel broken to be but I'm
not very good at logic do I have an
opinion on that I don't have an opinion
on that no
um
I will say this that uh when we're
talking essentially in the field of
formal logic right we're not talking
about other Logics in which
um you know contradictions can be true
like big alien logic or Maurice
blondel's logic of the moral life or all
these these other things that we can
talk about as well they're not as easily
mapped onto that you can't really
formalize hegel's uh ideas
um but no I don't really have opinions
on those sorts of things
um
Zach says any advice on building your
first philosophy class building one now
well that depends on what kind of
philosophy class You're Building
obviously you know uh intro is different
than ethics is different than you know
logic or whatever other thing you've
been assigned
I I you know I actually do have some
useful advice don't try to do too much
it's tempting especially like in an
intro class to throw way way too much
material at the students
and then you find that they're lost and
frustrated
and you know they're not retaining much
from week to week or let alone from
semester to semester
so you know figure out a couple things
a couple themes that you can bring up
over and over again and you know make
sure to draw the connections out for
them
um and the other thing I would say is
you know
put the bar for your expectations kind
of low I mean this this pertains more to
like
the American setting because I don't
know where where you are
um you could be in a place where maybe
students have had some philosophy but
you know a lot of uh students don't have
any clue what philosophy is or what a
philosophy class is going to be like and
they come in kind of anxious about that
so you know you don't want them to be
stifled or made too rigid by that
um
you know so you want to try to put them
at ease and and you can you can tell
them things like
uh there isn't a definition of
philosophy you know
um or one single way to do it it's a
it's a pluralistic
sort of discipline you know
uh say it says so here's the opposite
side of it any tips for an unmotivated
student
um
I mean it all depends on why you're
unmotivated doesn't it
you know if if uh I mean sometimes
people go to school and it's not the
right time for them like I know if I had
gone right into college right out of
high school
I probably would have dropped out of
college you know
um it wasn't the right time for me and I
I I teach I'm gesturing that like so I'm
thinking about Marquette University
which is you know 12 blocks that way I
sometimes I see these students and
they've like they've they're in college
because of other people's expectations
and it's it's tough for them to to stay
motivated because of that right
um because they they they're not really
into what they're supposed to be doing
so
if that's the case you know you might
want to think about whether it's a good
time to be in school whether you're
getting something out of it it could
also be like you know you made some
progress and then you just kind of got
burnt out you need to figure out how to
revitalize yourself and you know what to
do so I don't have any
um real generic advice there to
to give
um
all right uh minji been a subscriber for
years since I took intro to philosophy
going through your half hour Hegel to be
more erudite
thank you for what you do go evil sailor
yeah we'll see evil Sadler show up maybe
later on this month
um
I mean you know if the goal is to be
erudite
I don't know that Hegel is the the best
person to be
tackling you know somebody like uh Plato
or Cicero or Augustine somebody who who
is much more rhetorically or nature
right
um Hegel to to try to read Eagle hegel's
a terrible writer and uh you definitely
don't want to imitate his style
and a lot of his stuff is kind of Muddy
you know
um
and he often like I mentioned he often
doesn't tell you who the hell he's
talking about you know he doesn't he
doesn't quote texts uh except in
lectures so I mean studying Hagel is not
gonna hurt you but there may be more
direct ways to become more erudite
um
Akram if the abrahamic religions are
going to transform themselves in the
future which way do you think it's going
to be oh I I don't know I mean
usually we talk we're talking about like
Judaism and Christianity and Islam and
we could kind of include some others in
there as well and I mean look at
Christianity it's such a hot mess with
so many different things going on even
within the same denomination or church
or something like that I I don't I don't
I don't have a clue where they're gonna
go
so
uh Ricardo which top five philosophers
make you feel like you just read
straight Heat I don't know I don't I
don't know what reading straight heat
means it must be a contemporary term
that that people use that I just didn't
uh get
um
I mean I'll I'll just say that the
people that I
find most exciting to read
um
Lev shustoff you know
uh nature he's always worth going back
to him just off of course is drawing on
nietzsa pretty heavily
um
kind of like David Hume you know
um
you know Epictetus is pretty cool
and uh
who else would I throw in there
um
where you get real excited reading them
good question I mean I don't get I don't
get like all jazzed up that much
uh the fire thing I'm not quite sure
what that would would look like
all right Ken says unfortunately I know
very little classical Latin is there a
particular translation of Cicero you
would recommend well Cicero's written a
whole bunch of books so there is an a
translation of all of his stuff there's
different translations out there for the
different works
um
there's you know I mean the lobe
editions I like those because
[Music]
um
you've got the the Latin on the facing
page so you can always you know go back
and forth but those are usually older
translations
um
Cambridge has brought out a bunch of
Cicero translations in recent years that
have become if I'm if I'm you know if
I'm right about this they become kind of
standard use in academic uh settings so
yeah
um
all right well I don't have much to say
about that uh Mark who can we turn to to
help us understand the current political
climate that's been developing over the
last decade in the United States
well that's an interesting one because
there's a lot of like
not exactly like history repeating
itself but there's interesting
correspondences you know we're seeing
the rise of
of new forms of fascism and
um you know it goes under different
words sometimes using the same word like
integralism right in in Catholic circles
and this this has been done before you
can look at you know French thought in
the 20th century and see the same sort
of [ __ ] being bandied around by you
know Steve Bannon looks like a fatter
and uh less well put together Chara Mara
you know the guy who helped found oxyon
Francis
uh the movement that was eventually
condemned actually by by the Vatican but
drew a lot of Conservative Catholics uh
into it in the uh
you know the Arts and teens and 20s in
in French thought
um William shirer is uh Decline and
follow the French third Republic is
worth reading because of some of the
parallels that you can see going on but
we're also in you know a new situation I
mean I I don't think that there is a
analysis out there
um that neatly distinguishes how screwed
up our you know beloved constitutional
republic is you know our our
Constitution and our arrangements for
things are clearly Antiquated and
um all sorts of you know openings and
holes in them for abuse
um so I I don't know there's there's no
like one thinker who I would say helps
us understanding all understand all of
that we have to look at multiple
analyzes
a snake asks about Iran it talked about
Ein Rand earlier in in its um Sayed says
our professor once said Niche is a
pseudo philosopher what do you think
about that I'm sure you're your
professor has their reasons for saying
that and I'm sure that they're bad
reasons
so I mean calling so nietzsch's Niche is
clearly a major philosopher and the
inability to appreciate even if you
disagree with him uh what Nietzsche is
up to and the need to call him a pseudo
philosopher I would say reflects badly
on your professor
[Music]
um
Danny how would you respond to refute
Descartes evil demon hypothesis how
would you refute the simulation
hypothesis I don't see a need to refute
the simulation hypothesis I think that
the burden of proof falls on the
simulation people you know
um the evil demon hypothesis I mean you
could go to Descartes route right and uh
I just happen to have the meditations
right here you know
um
how does Descartes do it you know how do
you how do other people do it you know
um can you actually doubt everything
uh Hume thinks you can't purse thinks
you can't so I you know I'd read these
these thinkers who actually engage that
I don't how would I respond I don't
because it's not really a worry for me
uh Jordan would you consider GK
Chesterton a philosopher he wasn't
formally trained and his work is often
apologetical but it shocks me as the
philosophical instincts he has without
any formal education he had plenty of
formal education you don't have to have
I mean back then people read books you
know and there was a general culture
that you could participate in and it
included for a lot of philosophy so you
know you don't have to go to uh study in
a philosophy program to be a uh
well-versed in philosophy is he a
philosopher depends on how we Define
philosopher right I would say we can
call him that in a broad sense
and I don't think that a lot of his work
is actually apologetic a lot of his work
is essays and short stories and uh
novels you know
um some stuff that he writes I mean I'll
put it to you this way if you want to
call things like the Everlasting man
apologetic it's apologetic in a way
that's not boring and kind of schematic
the way that most apologetics tends to
be you know but Chesterton also knows
that people aren't convinced solely by a
rational argument or something like that
you know
Uh Kevin beak just Googled Googled
integralism kind of frightening yeah it
is
um Joni why are a lot of the
post-structuralists so against sigelian
dialectics
and I think it's it's in part so this is
kind of a good history of philosophy
thing right when you read French
philosophy in the 20th century and you
see them reacting against stuff you you
can't just imagine it to be like
hegelian dialectics per se it's hegelian
dialectics as people were doing it in
the French Academy when they're
rejecting Marxism they're not rejecting
all Marxism they're rejecting the kind
of crap that was going on in France at
the time when they're rejecting this
they're rejecting that you know it's
often much more driven by the sterility
and rigidity
of the way philosophy was being done in
in France you know
um it's not necessarily applicable
directly to
um the way things are in the states or
Canada or Britain or you know Germany or
pick wherever else you you want it to be
you know
um
R says which is best to read the
secondary source then read the primary
source or go straight to the primary
source there's no good answer for that I
mean it depends on you and the kind of
reader you are and how you're reading
and you know I mean I personally think
that you should probably take a stab at
the primary text first and you know see
what you can do with it no obviously
you're not going to understand most of
what you read and that's okay and then
you know rely on some secondary sources
to give you some understanding of it I
mean here's the one thing you don't want
to do just rely solely on secondary
sources about things right because you
have no clue whether the person's right
or not and the other thing you don't
want to do is like slavishly buy into a
secondary source particularly if it's
very schematically oriented like these
are the rationals so these are the
empiricists so then we could come to
know
um
because you're gonna like you're gonna
come in with these blinders that you've
accepted uncritically from somebody
else's reading
and
um
you know it's going to keep you from
reading the the primary text but with
any primary text if you want to get to
know it you're going to have to read and
re-read and reread and so it's perfectly
fine to go back and forth and back and
forth same thing by the way with the
videos that I do you know I don't think
that anybody should rely on my videos or
anybody else's as a substitute for
actually reading the text you know I I
think that
um if you want to understand Plato
you've got to actually read Plato at
some point in time otherwise you're
working with somebody's you know
imitation or Shadow to use platonic uh
you know language of the original
pattern that that you're supposed to be
checking out you know and you'd you
deprive yourself of kind of a a cool
um
opportunity to engage something that you
know people over Millennia have found
quite valuable
all right Fireball thoughts on to lose I
like to lose I'm not a fan of Duluth
with Qatari
um I think that he he does better work
on his own and
um I'm not a fan of delusions because
they often you know are pretty jargony
and they'll be like body with or without
organs body without organs you know and
you know I think there's a lot of like
readers of Duluth I think there's an
awful lot of jargon doing the work that
should be done by actual thinking which
is a point that the lose himself makes
over and over again right in his own
work
um
all right so Dr Beavis says funny I just
started reading capitalism schizophrenia
it's a tough tough book
yeah I mean
most most late 20th century French
philosophy is tough stuff to read you
know uh in part it's it's a function of
that style that they adopt a little bit
too clever a little bit too precious a
little bit too showing off which is not
helpful
um but you know
there's there's often some nuggets that
are worth bringing out
all right
um
Joe Stanberry what's your opinion on
God's violence in the Bible in
particular the few cases in the New
Testament
I mean I don't know what you're asking
me there are you asking me to like
decide whether God's good or not or
something like that in the new test or
the Old Testament
uh I mean if you read the Old Testament
you're not actually going to find that
much violence anyway you know you're
going to find a lot of human uh people
doing things sometimes you know because
God told them to do things sometimes
against what God told them to do uh I
think there's there's this caricature of
the awful Old Testament and the very
nice Meek New Testament that you know we
probably want to be a little bit more
realistic about I mean if you want a
book where God is a real [ __ ] look at
the last book of the New Testament which
by the way some of the people you know
in the early period were like
um
this book shouldn't be in here the the
you know the revelation of John right
um that's full of hateful imagery isn't
it so I I would avoid that dichotomy
um
snakes as if you read the stragatsuki
brothers books
hard to be a God is such a fantastic
novel I haven't yet I mean down the line
when I get to it but I've got so much
other reading to do people are saying
it's good and most of the times that
people are recommending uh science
fiction or fantasy or horror people to
me they've been pretty good so right now
I am finishing up
uh another fan recommendation that got
voted in uh Dan Simmons I've got you
know just a bit more of fall of Endymion
to go to finish up the Hyperion cantos
um pipeline do you have any stance on
pan psychism I've thrown a lot of the
term at the moment I don't take it
seriously I don't think that everything
is conscious so it's kind of a
non-starter for me
um
we're a little bit over time and I've
got a thing I got to do so I'll take a
few more rizzard how much reading would
you recommend for an undergraduate to do
every day or for a week it totally
depends on who the undergraduate is
right and how much time you have
available and you know how much reading
works for you
um you know you might you know if you're
lucky enough to be able to read eight
hours a day you might not be able to
read eight hours a day maybe you get to
like the six hour mark and your eyes are
glazed over and you're like [ __ ] I'm not
recognizing anything of what I'm
actually reading here so it's gonna vary
uh considerably I don't have
recommendations like that sort of thing
um
Kevin which modern philosophers
incorporate politics in their assessment
of a good life to any
um yeah I mean literally hundreds
you know I mean and it depends on what
you mean by modern are you talking about
contemporary are you talking about you
know the actual modern period which we
generally is like 1600s to you know the
uh 1800
um I mean
if you're talking about that period
Descartes himself does that Spinoza does
that Hobbs does that you know and we
could go on and on and on from from
there
um but if you're talking about
contemporary thinkers there's too many
to name you know
um
here's an interesting question this is a
good one to end on
did you ever lose yourself in your
philosophical development sometimes I
lose hope and entirety of my potential
and my studies is it normal to have ups
and downs and fill in a philosophical
career so that's actually a great
question
so
I'm not sure what Lose Yourself means
here like At first I thought you meant
like get so absorbed in something that
you're like not paying attention to
other things and that that certainly
happened to me at different points
um but I think judging from the rest of
what you're saying losing hope in your
potential and your studies is it normal
to have ups and downs yeah it's totally
normal
you're not a machine you know you are a
person and philosophy or whatever else
you're studying is just a part of your
life and it can be a very important
meaningful part of your life
but the other stuff that's going on
um
is important and not everything has to
be turned into like an opportunity to
practice philosophy or an opportunity to
like think about things I mean it's it's
fine to have like a year where you don't
read any philosophical texts and you're
just focusing on staying afloat
psychologically or health-wise or in
terms of
you know living your relations with with
other people I'll I'll tell you an
interesting story about a guy who some
of you heard me talk about before
Nick Barron who is teaching down in
southern Indiana
um he's a guy I met in graduate school
he came in around the same time as me
and we had some classes together and he
was kind of a shy you know unassuming
person but he really liked Augustine and
he ended up writing his dissertation on
Augustine
and so
um
he was ready to start work on his PhD
and his mom got sick and he had 11
brothers and sisters
and I guess they were all pricks I mean
he wouldn't describe him that way but
he's a really nice guy
way nicer than me
and I'll call him Pricks because not a
single one of them was willing to take
care of her as she was dying of cancer
so Nick leaves he took a leave of
absence and he went down to Southern
Indiana actually across because Southern
Illinois and Southern Indiana are about
you know on the same uh uh latitude
and he spent several years just
um taking care of her and the house and
all that sort of stuff as she slowly
died and then he did the all the other
stuff that was required too handling the
estate and dealing with all these prick
brothers and sisters who each wanted
their little share of the proceeds and
stuff like that and then he came back
and and I was I was just sort of
finishing up in the department when he
like you know walked into my office and
he's like hey I'm back and we chatted
and stuff like that and obviously it
took him a much longer time right
um sometimes things like that happen you
know
it's not like he couldn't
study philosophy afterwards
um that's okay for for things like that
to you know to give a priority to uh
matters like your family that can be
quite all right or your health your
mental health
um
you know other other things along those
lines there are going to be ups and
downs and so
I think it's there are some people for
whom that doesn't happen but most of us
we go through periods where we can be
more productive or less productive or
more interests that are less interested
and
um not all of that has to be turned into
wonderful opportunities for growth
either it's okay to have obstacles and
setbacks the obstacle doesn't always
have to become the way right we don't
have to do all this happy dappy
inspirational [ __ ] you know
um it's okay just to be
what we are and who we are and try to do
the best that we can with things and the
best doesn't always have to be like
somebody else's best so that that's what
I have to say about that and that's uh
where we'll leave off with um we do one
of these every month so if you didn't
get your uh question answered here
although I think I got to nearly all of
them uh you know we could do it next
time
um thanks for all the great questions
and uh I'll see you in some of the other
online events